ja es wird immer mehr bekannt über diese
wirklich dramatischen momente die sich
abgespielt haben am freitag dem tag an
dem donald trump eben eingeliefert wurde
hier in das motto reed
militärkrankenhaus seiner sauerstoff
level ist rapide gefallen angeblich man
habe immer künstlichen sauerstoff geben
müssen seine temperatur ist auf 39 94
grad nach oben gegangen auch ein relativ
hohes fieber er hatte probleme beim
atmen und ihr habt immer wieder gefragt
werde ich sein wie stan server 10 djerba
ist einer seiner guten freunde aus new
york der im frühjahr am corona virus
gestorben ist also alt also donald trump
hat gefragt ob er sterben wird erst dann
wurde sofort eben der hubschrauber der
helikopter bestellt um ihn ins
krankenhaus zu fliegen und hier geht es
ihm jetzt offensichtlich besser aber
selbst sein arzt schon kommt der eben
die system köpfige ärzte-team hier
leitet in dem krankenhaus der selbst hat
in der nacht auf heute noch bekannt
gegeben
obwohl es ihm besser geht ist er noch
nicht aus dem schneider man wir jetzt in
den nächsten tagen sehen müssen
oft hat man gesehen corona virus dass es
patienten vorübergehend besser geht und
dann bei der nächsten verschärfung der
krankheit es wirklich kritisch werden
könnte mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bet schaue ich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren